freaking news yeah
[Music]
it was their Crime of Passion to steal
others fashion
America's favorite bald criminal
crossdresser is back in the news
no not Jesse
Sam Brinton The Lex Luthor of non-binary
government hacks was busted once again
for allegedly stealing yet another
suitcase full of clothes
who needs that many suitcases I only
need 12.
this time a houston-based fashion
designer claims she lost a bag of
custom-made dresses at a DC airport back
in 2018.
finally something that's not mayor
Pete's fault
all right well
you'll never guess where the clothes
turned up
[Applause]
close very close
I don't know how you got that picture
close but guess again in a viral tweet
the designer said she spotted photos of
Sam posing in her one of a kind dress my
God Houston based fashion designer we
have a problem
and it appears that Sam Road tested more
than one poached piece from the bag
showing up at various events wearing
designs that bear a striking resemblance
to the stolen dresses
it's a move requiring a lot of balls no
no matter how they tuck them
the fashion designer reported it to
police and the FBI contacted her but
they haven't heard anything since giving
them the information but knowing salmon
airports it won't be long before we get
another
baggage claim
oh man uh Jeff if someone found your
luggage what would they find uh just a
ton of uh really nice dresses like this
with capes on them
no no no I actually this is two segments
in a row dude I feel very embarrassed
about this I've worked for NBC for so
long I thought this was a who wore it
best
so I'm a little embarrassed I I was
gonna go with the lady from Houston
all right just because I like ladies all
right
it's fair yeah you gotta go with what
you need neither one did it neither one
did it great but uh one's way better
looking
all right so you like ladies on the
streets and maybe freaks in the dresses
is that what we're saying no no no I
like just ladies
again pretty simple huh you gotta go
with what you know
okay Joey what would you say if you met
this person because I feel like I would
just go with bruh
which is gender neutral by the way I
spent a lot of time on this last night
so the the side by side of one of the
dresses the patterns don't match up and
I looked and I realized it's because
this is how you know this is a dude and
not an it or are they or anything else
this is a dude he put the dress on
backwards and probably had no idea like
I did the forensic analysis because I'm
telling you right now if I put a dress
on you know all my zippers are in the
front you know what I mean like that's
it's easy access it's necessary that is
a dude and lipstick I don't care what it
says about itself at any point in time
he doesn't even know how to put the
dress on and also the balls on this guy
to go steal a fashion designer's bag
with a bunch of one-of-a-kinds on it
like he had to pick that out on purpose
yeah I mean I'll always use the correct
pronouns I'll say they is an idiot like
they they is did you see that is insane
I use this they know it or not judge
you're a judge
have you ever seen a case like this in
your court of law no never but you know
what this is this is a classic uh Biden
employee okay this guy's have this guy
they like that
um they like that one yeah the guy is
with you know the department of energy
is that any surprise in the same
Department that wants all of us who
can't afford it to buy an electric
vehicle but this guy this is like his
third or fourth suitcase and they didn't
want to let him go I mean first of all
wouldn't you fire him just for looking
like an idiot I mean I
I guess that's not a crime but that's
not my core judge you can't fire him for
that oh you don't know me do you
my office is next time a thousand
percent wood yeah what if she just calls
in different places she doesn't work in
fires people
they listen I would
Tyrus I mean how many more of these do
you think there are oh there's hundreds
I think we're all laughing here but you
realize he's stocked this lady you
followed her that's what I'm saying yeah
like you know
um and then
to get there to see what my concern is
because why would somebody steal
somebody else's clothes to hide their
DNA that's why I look at it he's because
now no for real you don't you don't
between have you seen some of this
dude's photos
unfortunately Gutfeld forced us all to
see him and
it has pups and all this weird stuff he
does so and if a lot of it is nefarious
and seems to be so if you're wearing
other people's stuff the DNA is all over
the place and you could literally
somebody else could be playing for your
crime like I said you got scared about
your extension yeah because you don't
know what that person did what if they
were a murderer yeah so it's more than
just stealing bags maybe he's targeting
women he's targeting women
stealing their belongings and I would
just like to say
TSA always stops me when I have my
luggage and ask me for my ID
and I had one saying where's Tyrus at
and I said it's the T in the middle may
I go so what the hell are we doing
airport security they always stop me
like Hey sir you sure loves your legs
yeah he's also stealing women's struggle
and you get I know that some people who
are criminals like to like keep trophies
yeah they likes to wear trophies and
post photos from the scene of the crime
he's like a villain idiot he's like a
villain when Batman's run out of arrest
you know the writer's like we need a new
villain uh how about a guy who steals
women's dress wears them backwards
all right hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else